I would say that that when I was in law
school I was sort of enamored with
English law in English law is law was
and Prem basically even now is much less
protective of free speech and more
protective of order order in society
then our law is for example I thought it
made sense then that if somebody was on
trial the press shouldn't be allowed to
publish information about the trial
until it was pretty well over certainly
information which could influence a
juror a confession which might not be
admitted into evidence prior criminal
record for example I was in some public
speaking contests that I one of which in
which I was taking the position in
college that we should move more towards
the English system my views have changed
they changed pretty rapidly after law
school about that as well as the breath
as I view it of the First Amendment for
a number of reasons one is that I got a
much better sense of what journalists do
certainly what they do at their best and
the and the role that they can play lots
that was published during the Watergate
scandal in the mid-1970s couldn't have
been published in England because there
were always trials going on to do with
it with the scandal and a lot of what
was published about the Nixon
administration could not have been
published and would not have been
published in England under the English
law that I had previously liked so much
we learned something something else
which affected my views
and that is that the government is not
always candid with the public that we
need government and we need it to work
but we need the ability to be critical
and the information from which we can be
critical of government to and only under
American law is is that as possible as
it is here possible because you really
can't get in trouble here by criticizing
government by having documents to back
you up by gathering information we have
a Freedom of Information Act here which
is not required by the First Amendment
but which which supplements the First
Amendment in a very important way of it
really based on the notion that the
government is supposed to serve the
public it's supposed to be
representative of the public and so that
unless there's a really good reason to
keep material secret the presumption
should be that it's public and as I've
practiced law in the area and read books
about American history and talk to
people I've more and more come to the
view that while there are risks and
genuine ones of living in a society in
which people are so free to say so much
with so little risk that for us at least
it's a much safer system as well as a
much freer system because of the
openness of our society and our
willingness to let people and
institutions have their say
I think the state of First Amendment law
is good in the country I think the state
of free speech is generally good there
are exceptions but i think that the
difficulty the existential threat to
newspapers in the country is itself
threatening of free speech in a
different way I do think newspapers have
played a very special role with respect
to educating the public exposing
misconduct and the like in a way which
no other institution really has matched
and I think that the economic
difficulties that the press is having
opposed very real risks for the public
itself I mean the public the public is
doing it it's not a matter where the
government has done something wrong here
the public is obviously free to choose
what to buy and what not to buy and you
know that they'd rather see things for
free on the internet and then to buy a
newspaper but the the effect of that I
think is is deeply threatening to to the
country as we know it in the best way
things change that's both inevitable and
generally a good thing but if one of the
ways things ultimately change is that we
don't have a vibrant press with respect
to the written word I think the public
will truly to be the loser